I told you guys six weeks ago, seven, eight weeks
ago, that there's this growing list of things that
Joe Biden claims he will do on day one. And I
told you that we're going to hold Biden to that.
I'm going to tell you on day two whether Joe
Biden did those things. And if he didn't,
if the day one priorities get pushed back to
week one or month one or the first 100 days,
that would be a broken promise by Joe Biden.
And I can't tell you how thrilled I am to be
able to report that Joe Biden did it. He filed
17 executive orders yesterday. There's a ten
or a dozen more coming today which have not yet
been signed. So I can't report on those and doing
really, really important things. Much of this is
by necessity, covid related, but much more than
that. So some of the executive orders that Joe
Biden filed yesterday on coronavirus Joe Biden,
he promised he would do it and he did it. It's
a 100 day masking challenge. It's not a mandate.
It's a request that for these next hundred days,
as the vaccines start working their way through,
the population already starting to see a decrease
in hospitalizations thanks to the vaccines
that everybody wear a mask and indeed, a Joe Biden
did sign a mandate for masks at federal buildings,
which is within his purview. Joe Biden can't
mandate masks in state buildings or in random
businesses or out in public or in people's homes.
And he's not trying to do that, but doing exactly
what he promised to do on masks, hundred day
challenge and mandate in federal buildings.
Joe Biden immediately shut down Trump's
withdrawal from the World Health Organization.
That was a disastrous idea
at the worst possible time,
immediately putting Dr. Anthony Fauci as the
head of the delegation to the show in a predawn
meeting this morning. Foushee already meeting
with the show. This is I mean, in 24 hours how
things have changed on the economy. Joe Biden has
extended the nationwide moratorium on evictions
and foreclosures until at least the end of the
first quarter, March 31st. And he has extended
the pause on student loan payments and interest
for Americans with federal student loans until
at least September 30th of twenty twenty one.
He has not forgiven any student loan debt yet,
and that's something many of us want to see him
do. But this is a big deal as well. Joe Biden has
rejoined the Paris climate accord, a process that
will actually take close to 30 days immediately,
reversing what Donald Trump did in bailing on
the Paris climate accord. And also Joe Biden
reversing Donald Trump's action by canceling the
Keystone XL pipeline period canceled and directing
agencies to review and reject and reverse, rather,
100 Trump actions on the environment. I said this
must be done. Trump's damage to the environment
by loosening regulations has been disastrous.
Joe Biden, day one, saying undo
all of it. Joe Biden rescinded
the Trump administration 1776 commission.
This was that patriotic education nonsense
that Donald Trump put in place that's done.
He also put in a executive order to prevent
workplace discrimination on the basis of
sexual orientation or gender identity.
There are a number of other sort of more minor
executive orders, but very importantly, Joe Biden
for defying DACA after Trump tried to gut it,
reversing the Trump administration's restriction
on entry for passport holders from several Muslim
majority countries. That's the reversal of the
so-called Muslim country. Travel ban undid Trump's
expansion of immigration enforcement within the
U.S. and stopped construction on the border
wall of. Very, very important stuff, there are
a number of other executive orders that Joe Biden
signed yesterday and more that he will sign today,
but this is all very good and very important.
And what is really important to understand here,
and we're going to play some clips of it,
triggered Fox News host about these orders
soon. What we found out is that a relatively small
number of bad actors, Trump included, who the
majority of the country didn't vote for. Remember,
even in 2016, Trump got less than half of the
vote of those who voted and half the country
didn't vote in 2016. A very small number of
bad actors can do a lot of damage. And now Joe
Biden gets to undo that damage by the exact same
legal provisions that Trump used to do the
damage, many of which were executive orders.
But there's a general principle, which is
that it's almost always easier to break
and destroy things than it is to build
things. Consider building a house.
You've got to clear the land and then dig out
a foundation and pour the foundation and then
frame it and then put a roof on and windows and
doors and toilets that Trump said you have to
flush 10 or 15 times and then you bring a wrecking
ball in and in 10 minutes you reduce it to rubble.
That is a perfect analogy, too much
of how we saw the Trump administration
operate in very little time. Trump was able to
destroy global alliances that took decades to
build and to strengthen. Trump was able to
buy failing on the virus for a few months
irreversibly set us back OK. So I think we
understand the concept. A lot of right wingers are
finding themselves very triggered by Joe Biden's
executive orders. Let's talk about that next.